for those of you who love Tick Tock and
solely rely on Tick Tock for your
content to go viral you may want to
listen to this video you may not like it
matter of fact you may not want to
listen to this video because it's going
to hurt a little bit but let me get into
it so I was very hesitant of getting on
Tick Tock I was convinced Tick Tock was
part of China bite dance and they had
certain things that were doing behind
closed doors I read all the articles I
read the disclaimer I read what they
stand stood for finally I said you know
what I don't care if I get kicked off a
tick tock I really want to find out if
there's any credibility behind all the
criticism that Tick-Tock get for those
of you who love Tick Tock and use it
regular and you love the app there's one
organization you cannot criticize God
forbid you do on Tick Tock you'll see
what happens to your numbers by the way
it's very important for you to watch
this video it's tough for some of you to
watch it but it's important for you to
watch this video because remember what
happened to vine there were all these
Vine celebrities oh my God 5 billion
views 10 million views Boom the app shut
down 80 percent of celebrities nobody
knew about afterwards six months 12
months later took a lot for some people
able to make the adjustments you may
want to know what's happening with Tick
Tock because they're one president away
from being banned in no time so having
said that I'm going to share with you a
social experiment I did with my own
account on Tick Tock to see if this was
true or not and I have proof for you
with pure data and you'll be able to
make a decision for yourself so let's
get right into it
[Music]
so before we get into the video a couple
things if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel and if it makes you think
share it with others so two timetables
we measured on how videos we're doing
first one is from June 7 2022 to August
5th of 2022 which is roughly 264 clips
that were uploaded during that time on
Tick Tock then we looked at from August
6 2022 until November 23rd which are on
722 Clips were uploaded you're going to
see a major difference in numbers so
there's four category of videos we're
gonna break down first one is videos
getting between zero to twenty thousand
views second is video is getting between
20 to 100 000 views then a hundred
thousand two million and last but not
least at a million plus now why are we
looking at August 50s because August 5th
is when I uploaded a video criticizing
the one organization the one name you
cannot criticize on Tick Tock viewership
dropped 10 200 x you'll see 100x when I
show it to you and daily followership
used to be 50 000 to 75 followers on The
Tick Tock for three months straight
every month to down to three to five
thousand followers on a monthly basis so
when you look at the first round June 7
to August 5th here's what happened
videos between zero to twenty thousand
views were 99. videos between 20 to 100
000 views for a hundred and Eleven
Hundred two million 45 videos got over a
hundred thousand two million views and
nine videos got over a million views now
keep in mind this is when the account
was smaller I only had forty thousand
followers or eighty thousand followers a
hundred thousand followers so I'm
getting a million plus views on videos
on a very small account that I just
started because I didn't really trust
Tick Tock yet then boom on August 5th I
upload a video criticizing China this is
what the video looked like here's what
the video was I put this video up if you
come out this strong and your name is
China
and you want to be the world leader you
cannot make a threat like this and not
deliver oh
which means
she has to know this Biden has to know
this we have to be on alert and we have
to know this isn't a small country
saying this this isn't a billionaire
saying this this is our number one enemy
in the world who wants to take over us
they had a vision called made in China
2025 it was by 2025 China wanted to be
the ruler of the World when they say
this you best believe behind closed
doors everybody needs to be ready for
this it almost looked like numbers
instantaneously change and my people
would come up to me at the office the
past something's going on with Tick Tock
I'm like guys stop with all this stuff
jump into conclusion no give it another
week give it another week give it
another week Pat look at the numbers
look at the comparison look I'm like I'm
telling you give it one more month Pat
look at the numbers finally after
looking all these numbers testing you're
showing it right next to each other I
said maybe the team's got a good
argument let's take a look at this
here's what happened after or I uploaded
that video about China so once again
between June 7 to August 50 was 264
videos we were measuring now we're going
to look at August 6th to November 23rd
722 so when you look at it side by side
here's what you see Zero to twenty
thousand views you ready
720 videos were only between 0 to 20 000
views you want to know how many videos
were twenty thousand two hundred
thousand views only two
one of them was a Buffett video and one
of them was an Antonio Brown video do
you want to know how many videos got
over a hundred thousand views two
million only one and you know how many
got over a million zero so let me get
this straight when the account was
smaller I got 111 view videos to go
between 20 to 100 000 when the channel
is bigger when the account is bigger on
720 videos we're measuring only two got
between 20 to 100 000. when the account
was smaller I got 45 to get to 100 to a
million when the accounts bigger only
one get 100 over a million when the
account's smaller I get nine over a
million when the accounts bigger I get
zero over a million makes you think so
so keep in mind it's more clips
fewer opportunities over a hundred
thousand fewer Clips more over a hundred
thousand it's kind of like a hundred at
bats you're hitting 40 home runs for
example here a thousand at bats you're
hitting one home run very weird then I
said well let's look at the content to
see if it's getting better or worse
because maybe numbers are not grown on
all the other channels here's what we
noticed the last two or three months
have been the biggest month in the
history of our content ever on our all
our YouTube channels pbd podcasts by
Timmy shortclips pbd podcast just won
over around 430 000 Subs by Timmy
shortcuts just went over four hundred
thousand Subs you know you got value
team just won over 3.7 million Subs my
Instagram account just went over 3.4
million every Twitter is growing
everything's grown Owen except for one
thing Tick Tock so let's compare the
clips maybe the content went lower so
look at the clips here same Clips we
uploaded on Instagram how many views did
they get versus the same Clips we
uploaded on Tick Tock here's the results
so here's a clip I did about buffets on
Instagram 1.3 million views on Tick Tock
20 000 views here's a clip about Shaq on
Instagram 1.5 million Tick Tock ten
thousand two hundred here's another one
about men their testosterone level going
lower one million versus Tick Tock 7
600. here's another one 970 this was
about houses good time to buy 970 000
views versus fifteen thousand views
here's a video about staying positive
3.9 million views on Instagram only 5600
views on Tick Tock here's one about
reading books one million views on
Instagram 9 500 views on Tick Tock
here's about sales people 1.1 million on
Instagram Tick Tock 12 900. here's one
about helping people 933 000 views
versus 11.9 000 views here's one about
marriage on Instagram 9.6 million views
here's on Tick Tock 9600 views that's a
thousand times less so somebody may say
well on Instagram you have 3.4 million
followers on Tick Tock you only have
260. what's 260 times a thousand times
ten is 2.6 million times 100 is 26
million times a thousand is 260 million
followers I don't have 260 million
followers on Instagram the numbers don't
make sense let me continue Michael burry
932 versus 12 900. Jewish money 5.9
million versus 12 900. Rolex 3.1 million
versus 16 600. Detroit 1 million versus
eleven thousand art 1.1 million versus
9700 another Buffet video 2 million
versus seventeen thousand nine hundred
not having kids 1.2 million versus 3200
Tate 1.2 million versus twenty one
thousand seven hundred so now you saw
the data you get to make a decision 264
videos like the 722 like that what that
kind of that's kind of weird and then
the other content is doing better on
Insta and other places than it is on
Tick Tock and here's the other part I'm
not looking for you to say oh my God
poor Pat I have a great life I'm not
sitting here that I need sympathy
whatsoever I'm a leader I take
responsibility for the words that's
coming out of my mouth how to improve
how to adjust feed my mind that's all on
me I want you to hear from what other
experts have to say and influencers have
to say about this four names I'm going
to give to you one is Elon Musk the
other one is Scott Galloway Scott
Galloway cannot stand Elon Musk Scott
Galloway said musk will never buy
Twitter he's just playing with everybody
he'll never cut the check and every day
Scott Galloway criticizes musk on
Twitter so they're not on the same page
what Rogan said what a comedian Andrew
Schultz said Andrew Schultz said the
best thing on one of the podcasts I'm
paraphrasing what he said he said the
algorithm in China
benefits kids who are making things that
are interesting engineer creating
something it's getting them to be
smarter those videos go viral in China
but algorithms in U.S favor boys and
girls who do silly dumb [ __ ] to get
viral and get attention because they
want the reward in America to be do
stupid things to get recognized so the
algorithms are dumbing up the kids in
America they can do that because they
control the algorithm Scott Galloway
went on Tick Tock and said the following
he said there's no difference with the
CCP and a Chinese company a CO can
disappear for four weeks people under
the age of 18 are not spending more time
on Tick Tock than all the other apps
combined these are his words Tick Tock
needs to be banned for stop he said that
to Bill Maher and Bill Mars like whoa
whoa whoa Trump wasn't a fan even
Biden's not necessarily a big fan of
tick tock even though he's on it very
actively during the campaign here's what
musk said musk said Tick Tock is
destroyed following civilization and a
roguing gets on his podcast and reads
the entire terms of service and people
are saying wait a minute is that really
on the terms and service yes it is said
we collect information about the device
you use to access the platforms such as
your IP address your region and user
agent mobile carrier time zone settings
identifiers for advertising purposes
model of your service device your device
system networks it keeps it says are you
kidding me they really track the way you
move your finger they track the way your
keystrokes which means they're trying to
find out everything about everything
you're doing this is a app that's
eventually going to get banned it's
banned already in Indonesia in
Bangladesh India ban Tick Tock it's
banned in Syria for different reasons
it's been in many different places and
very soon it's going to be banned in
America because they are manipulating
the way you are receiving content it's
just a matter of time
foreign
[Music]